l'état doit retrouver le sens de
l'anticipation dans son discours de
politique générale jean castex a donc
confirmé le grand retour du commissariat
général au plan sa mission définir une
perspective et identifier les futurs
gisements de croissance a dit le nouveau
premier ministre
alors faut-il voir dans ce retour du
plan un gadget politique ou un véritable
tournant pour notre économie
on en parle de ce pas avec vous jacques
sapir en duplex de notre studio du
quartier de l'opéra
soyez le bienvenu jacques bonjour
stéphanie alors jacques vous avez été un
grand spécialiste de l'économie
soviétique ce retour du plan cela vous
vous parle que faut-il en penser
oui effectivement ça me parle alors il
faut tout de suite dire que la
planification française n'avait
strictement rien à voir avec la
planification soviétique l'économie
soviétique c'était une économie
planifiée
alors que la planification française
effectivement c'était un système qui
devait je dirais assurer une
coordination entre les efforts faits par
l'état par le secteur public et les
efforts faits par le secteur privé
donc là effectivement on a eu ce qu'on
appelle l'ardente obligation du plan de
en fait jusqu'à 2006 en réalité ça a été
un petit peu moins puisque le plan n'a
été pertinent que jusqu'à la fin des
années 70 c'est au début des années 1980
mais il a donné quand même d'assez bons
résultats alors jacques en quoi
consistait ce plan qui accompagnait les
trente glorieuses et même au delà
alors justement il faut savoir que le
plan c'était en réalité une idée qui
était déjà à la menthe c'était une idée
qui était dans l'air du temps par
exemple dans les années 30 ce qui s'est
passé c'est que après guerre au monde à
libération
et bien évidemment une première chose
qui a d'une certaine manière imposer
l'idée du plan c'était tout simplement
l'ampleur de la reconstruction qu'il y
avait à faire
après beaucoup d'économistes et même des
hommes politiques ont dit mais il ne
s'agit pas simplement de reconstruire on
ne peut pas d'une certaine manière
retournez à la france de 1939 il va
falloir modernisé il va falloir
progresser
réindustrialiser la france et donc c'est
aussi pour cela que la planification a
été lancé et comme je voulais dit
évidemment cette planification
elle a finalement donné d'assez bons
résultats alors quand on parle du
plongeon qu'on évoque également des
échecs cuisants comme le plan calcul des
années 60 alors est c'est une si bonne
idée que cela devrait susciter le plan
on peut se poser la question
oui alors effectivement vous avez tout à
fait raison c'est fini de parler de
l'échec du plan calcul même si c'est en
réalité un demi il faut savoir
simplement que le plan quelques unes
et il a été d'une certaine manière le
produit des militaires il a été le
produit d'un espèce d'impératif
militaire c'était la dissuasion
en fait on voulait des ce qu'on appelait
des calculateurs on n'appelait pas
encore ça réellement d un des
ordinateurs pour faire l'ensemble des
calculs qui permettrait à la france de
se doter de la bombe à hydrogène
c'est ça fonctionnait dans le domaine
militaire
évidemment ça n'a pas fonctionné dans le
domaine civil c'est pour ça que je
considère que le plan calcul ça a été un
demi échec
maintenant il faut savoir que les plans
en règle générale on était des grands
succès il ne faudrait pas du tout que
cet arbre du plan calcul cache ses
succès le premier plan qui est le plan
fait part à jean monnet le premier haut
commissaire il a permis de jeter les
bases de la reconstruction de mieux
utiliser d'ailleurs l'aide américaine du
plan marshall et de construire les
infrastructures le deuxième plan le plan
hirsch du nom du deuxième haut
commissaire et bien ce plan mire il a
été consacrée essentiellement au
développement de la recherche
développement de l'éducation mais aussi
de la modernisation de l'agriculture
quelque chose qui était extrêmement
important dans une france où il est bien
les agriculteurs représenter 30% de la
population active en 1946
et puis les troisième et quatrième plan
qui conscients qu'ils correspondent en
fait au début de la vème république
c'était des plans sous la direction de
jean macé ça a été des plans qui ont été
d'une certaine manière dédiée au
développement des industries de
consommation mais aussi et surtout à
l'amélioration extrêmement importante de
là
compétitivité de l'économie française
alors jacques
aujourd'hui elle coiffe servir et un tel
plan alors si on reprend les
déclarations mêmes que ce soit celle
d'emmanuel macron ou celle de jean
castex
on voit très bien qu'il y a en fait deux
grandes priorités
nous devons retrouver notre souveraineté
en particulier dans le domaine de la
santé et des industries sanitaires et
puis il y à ce grand programme pour
assurer la transition énergétique
alors bien évidemment ces deux grands
projets nécessitent le type de
coordination entre le secteur public et
le secteur privé qui implique d'une
certaine manière un commissariat au plan
on le voit bien dans le domaine de la
santé où il faudra non seulement
évidemment comme on y produire des
masses pour dire des respirateurs
produit du matériel pour les tests il
faudra d'une certaine manière développer
de manière très importante cette filière
pour assurer la souveraineté et
l'indépendance nationale
et puis dans le domaine de la transition
énergétique
il s'agit d'une certaine manière
d'accélérer le passage à des libres 1
des énergies non carbonées accélérer le
développement de la filière à hydrogène
là encore on voit que selon hra que cela
aura des conséquences structurantes
extrêmement importantes sur l'économie
française
prenons par exemple l'un des points qui
a été évoqué par le président de la
république lors de son interview il a
parlé de sa volonté de re développer le
fret ferroviaire de redévelopper les
trains dits de campagne les trains de
nuit devrait on voit bien qu'il y à là à
travers ce re développement du rail qui
est une chose extrêmement important il y
à bien une notion d'aménagement du
territoire
et justement l'aménagement du territoire
c'était la deuxième jambe du plan car
avec le commissariat général au plan
eh bien nous avions aussi la délégation
à l'action territoriale et à l'action
rural la datar qui a joué un rôle au
moins aussi important que le
commissariat général au plan pour une
certaine manière structurée l'ensemble
de l'espace économique français a donc
vous croyez à la planification jacques
c'est pas tellement la question de
croire ou de ne pas quoi si vous voulez
c'est de constater que la planification
une certaine forme de planification et
bien ça fonctionne ça fonctionnait en
france mais ça fonctionnait aussi dans
d'autres pays on peut prendre par
exemple le cas du japon le cas de la
corée du sud par exemple vient
maintenant ce qu'il faut dire aussi
c'est qu'il ne faudrait pas que cette
idée ne servent en fait au gouvernement
car réaliser un espèce de coup de
communication
si on veut effectivement ressusciter le
commissariat général au plan et bien il
faudra lui donner du pouvoir
il faudra lui donner une forme de
contrôle sur les investissements publics
il faudra lui donner du pouvoir pour
qu'il négocie avec le secteur privé
d'égal à égal
on voit que d'une certaine manière c'est
une idée qui impose d'une certaine
manière des choix importants
et justement c'est la question est ce
que ces choix
le gouvernement est il prêt à les faire
et la question évidemment aussi est-ce
que cela peut fonctionner aujourd'hui
effectivement et on pense immédiatement
aux règles de l'union européenne parce
que il est clair si vous voulez que
cette planification en dix ans ce crs de
nouveau commissariat général au plan et
bien il va devoir intervenir dans des
domaines où existe en réalité toute une
série de réglementations européennes par
exemple les réglementations sur la
concurrence
le commissariat général au plan pourrait
vouloir lever ces réglementations
pourrait vouloir imposer peut-être de
manière partielle peut-être de manière
temporaire
certaines mesures de type
protectionnistes bref on voit très bien
qu'il n'ya pas de cohérence à dire
souveraineté européenne est à dire dans
le même temps eh bien on veut recréer
une planification
vous savez c'est très joli de dire je
vais me réinventer mais encore faut-il
apporter des preuves
et là nous n'avons aucune preuve que
emmanuel macron est réellement prêts à
assumer ce que signifierait la
recréation de ce commissariat général au
plan alors justement on parle beaucoup
de rock
et le poste de haut commissaire au plan
cela devrait être annoncée avec la suite
de la formation du gouvernement de jean
castex et on parle de nommer une
personnalité politique de premier plan
qu'ont pensez vous alors oui pourquoi
pas créer effectivement ce poste de haut
commissaire au plan a poste d'ailleurs
le haut commissaire au plan avec statut
quasiment deux ministres et il
participait en tant que tel au conseil
des ministres
mais après c'est pas tellement la
question du nom qui est important c'est
la question des attributions qui l'aura
c'est la question du périmètre d'action
qui l'aura et donc c'est sur tous ces
points qui sont des points extrêmement
sensible que l'on attend effectivement
un des choses précises de la part du
gouvernement
et effectivement tant qu'on n'en saura
pas plus
eh bien on pourra toujours avoir un
doute et sur la personne également est
très curieux on parle beaucoup par
exemple de françois bayrou comme haut
commissaire alors voilà c'est un des
bruits qui lie actuellement et c'est un
des bruits qui font penser qu'on serait
plutôt face à un coup de communication
c'est pas que j'ai quoi que ce soit
contre françois biron qui a été
d'ailleurs un très bon ministre de
l'éducation nationale pour les cas un
ministre qui était nettement supérieur à
nombre de ses successeurs
mais enfin les premiers commissaire au
plan si on excepte jean monnet et encore
les premiers commissaire au plan
des gens comme etienne hirsch par
exemple ou pire pierre macé où michelle
albert ou qui arrive qu sait encore qui
est une personnalité avec laquelle j'ai
un petit peu travaillé dans les années
1990 c'était tous des hauts
fonctionnaires
c'étaient tous des gens qui étaient
choisis sur leurs compétences sur leur
maîtrise de leur domaine et non pas sur
un je dirais une image politique
donc c'est là où on vous effectivement
l'ampleur du problème est en fait ce que
l'on peut se dire c'est que la personne
qui aurait peut-être le meilleur profil
pour être le haut commissaire c'est le
premier ministre actuel c'est monsieur
jean castex qui correspond tout à fait à
ce type de définition mais qui se trouve
être justement le premier ministre
alors va pour conclure je me sens plutôt
réservé sur ce retour du plan on peut
dire ça comme ça
alors réservez non mais je veux dire que
j'ai une crainte c'est que cette idée de
recréer un de ressusciter le
commissariat général plan qui est unique
qui est une bonne idée qui est une idée
dont nous avons besoin c'est absolument
incontestable et bien que cette idée
elles ne servent en fait qu'à faire un
espèce de coup de pub un espèce de coup
de communication
et si cela devait être le cas eh bien ça
serait assez grave parce que cela aurait
fait perdre un temps précieux à
l'économie française car de toutes les
manières il nous faudra bien et le plus
tôt sera le mieux
recréer un organisme qui est la fonction
du commissariat général au plan merci
jacques on verra évidemment ce que
l'avenir nous dira de cette idée merci à
vous